uh now we'll get to the uh motivational
uh performing in just a little bit but
the first thing i want to ask you you've
been on the show
a couple times i believe and you're a
fantastic performer thank you
uh and and no one rocks harder i think
than than andrew w.k
thank you how many i want to ask you how
many party songs have you written cause
i was looking through your catalogue of
songs and i was realizing that
partying is a theme with you how many
party songs do you think you've written
songs with the word party in the title i
guess so yeah
it's time to party right long live the
party
right party hard right party till you
puke
right big party big party dance party
dance party and
uh the newest one is called party party
party
taking it back to basics you're going
back and you're adding more parties do
you think you'll ever write party party
party
party and just you know kick it up a
notch i think they'll leave that one to
you
okay yeah that's a party everyone wants
to go to yeah
uh yeah so uh what is the key do you
think to writing a good party song
because it is a whole genre of rock
what's the key also yeah well every song
to me is really a party song in the
terms of
in terms of celebration yes in terms of
enjoying yourself and having fun and
that's what i have looked for
in making music but i don't think that
there's any particular
aspect to having fun that is necessary i
think it's up to each individual to find
their own way
right and that's been my main focus
personally and and communicating with
other people is to say what do you want
to do to have fun well you know i've you
know watched you hear on the show
obviously and and then today we're
watching a video of a lot of your
dvd of a lot of your concerts and there
really is this insane i don't know how
you do it
you have that kind of energy we just saw
in the clip you'll have it for like two
hours on stage which is just pure
madness i don't know how you do it
it's uh there's a will there's a will to
do it yeah and i
i i focus on that it's the same will
that makes me get up in the morning
is the same will that makes me spazz out
yeah yeah see but i don't
many i don't see how you could i mean
yeah there's a will to do it but at
certain point you must have like three
different hearts pumping in your chest
you know what i mean it seems impossible
to me that you can just maintain that
level
maybe when you say that three other
hearts i think it's the hearts of the
people in the audience that end up
coming together and giving me energy
that's disgusting uh
that totally creeped me out so you rip
their hearts out of their chests
and stuff them into your own perfect
frankenstein superman yeah great
uh that's horrible um you okay
motivational performer
what is your message tell us what's your
message now to people and i'm guessing
young people
the song party hard for example the one
of the main lines and that is
is is we must party now well we do what
we want we
we we we party we do what we want my
message
is first of all love yes and to emanate
love in every direction through music
through talking through whatever it is
but with that love in mind and feeling
that empowered
state that love puts you and i want
people to do whatever they want to do
and i think that there sometimes can be
confusion or i've noticed even my own
life that there's
moments of confusion where you feel like
you can't do what you want for example
conan
yes i imagine you coming in here every
day there may have been times when you
thought
wow it'd be great to not come in today
and do the show because you're here five
days a week for years
and year after year and it wears down
and
there might be a time when uh the
perspective gets lost and you feel
obligated and you feel like you have
this responsibility that you're trapped
in this show
and you can't break out and i'm here to
tell you that you can
you didn't have to come in today and
neither did i
no you're right i quit getting out of
here i'm totally getting out of here
no no i still i see what your point is i
see what your point
everybody i mean this is my dream job i
love this job but occasionally there are
moments say when a cat over there's
hands come on
there are moments where your soul leaves
your body for a minute
and you think i wish i was digging a
dick somewhere
uh i wish i was a professional prize
fighter or a street urchin anything else
or sailing the high seas in the 17th
century stealing gold
uh the fact is you still you still came
in and that
is what makes this special everybody
here chose to be here i chose to be here
you chose to be here
that's the energy actually a bunch of
these people have left
are these the the the prisoner we ship
them in yeah
no uh it's it's but it's true so that's
what you're saying is you
you uh it's it's uh it's finding those
moments realizing that you have the will
that you choose to be uh who you are you
choose to do what you do
exactly now why motivational performer
most people say motivational speaker
what makes you a motivational performer
well there's certainly
there's been talking much like i'm
talking now i'll talk when i've been
doing these lectures and these
appearances but
that's too limiting to say it's just
speaking i i want to perform
motivational performance enables me to
to get up and
and stop talking right
incredible
i i just had that moment again where i
wanted to be doing something else
[Applause]
you're saying if you move you get your
whole energy up is that what you're
saying yeah
you break free you gotta break free
you got a great
i broke free i feel like in that moment
i tore everyone's brains out of their
heads in the audience and stuff them
into my head that's the idea it's the
spontaneous
quality of it so you'll do that and that
helps actually that changes that's that
makes it all right i want everyone to be
in a state of empowerment
yeah and out of breath yeah well that's
and feeling ridiculous yeah that's all
good
well andrew w.k will be giving a lecture
at carnegie mellon university in
pittsburgh pennsylvania tomorrow evening
you're a good man i like it
thank you so much